so here is he's a diagram but maybe you
want to copy it I particularly want to
get the relationship between slices and
shells I want you to see it and I want
you to be able to be very comfortable
with how the formulas for each one
relate to each other okay we've been
doing this for a while now yeah so
slices how do I get slices out of a
shape like this notice here's my um
here's a shape okay the area that I am
rotating is actually just a rectangle
maybe here can you see it
there's my rectangle that and I've
rotated it around the y-axis okay so if
I wanted to do this particular bother
you buy slices how would I do it what
kind of shape would I get now should I
sit where do I slice what direction my
slicing it when you do slices slices
slices are perpendicular to the axis of
rotation right well we know this don't
we okay so I'm gonna slice this way okay
a cross off the top if you like and I
will go further down okay so when you
slice is the cost you're gonna get this
shape then we gave it a name right
we called this would we call it an
annulus right Lori if you like an
annular disc okay that's the kind of
shape you get if you slice it across
like so I think now alternatively this
is what you learned last time when I was
in here we don't have to slice a cross
right perpendicular to the axis of
rotation we can slice the other way or
rather we can cut the other way okay so
if I did that for instance if I took a
portion like that there you go
this is that is parallel to the axis of
rotation so when I rotate this around
what am I going to get we call it a
shell don't we if I took this innermost
part here you get something like this
okay except it would be Hollow
it's a infinitesimally thin width right
and then you add them all up okay that's
why you should all have diagrams drawn
like this but it's a bit
to our picture and really understand
what's going on okay sir first on is
let's get this guy up okay now here's my
slice okay so can you see I've watched
I've tried anyway okay well look at this
thing and we've taken a slice off okay
now just because of the particular shape
I've chosen all the slices would
actually be the same wouldn't they
okay but in any other case you know
you'd have a whole bunch of different
you know similar slices but they don't
be different size and so on okay so do
you remember to express the volume from
a slice right slices we said the volume
would be equal to okay and we think
about these um these disks right as the
disks get really really thin okay so we
said look there's a limit involved now
for this the slices are going to be thin
vertically aren't they're thin vertical
okay so we call these anything we like
but I think a good name would be dr.
wine okay because they're they're
vertical discs okay they're very thin
that way right so that's sorry that's
what each of the disks is is going to be
its thickness right then I want to add
up all of the disks right all the dips
now because I'm slicing across this way
I have a whole bunch of disks City on
top each other up vertically okay so
therefore it'll be frog and then you
just pick whatever your boundaries are
right remember this this is a to be okay
now remind me what's the hoops what's
the area of an annulus how do I work
this thing out big circle - the middle
circle right so this is what we came up
with they both have plan them because
they're both circles and then you've got
the big circle - the little circle okay
now I'm going to um this is a bit tricky
I want to remind you of the fact that
each of these radii right well I mean
sometimes as in this case sometimes the
radii are constant but they don't have
to be they don't have to be they can
change and wiggle all that kind of thing
so really these ours right there are
actually functions it's R of X
square right it's a function of X and
this little R is also a function little
RS okay so there you go
pi big circle little circle but of
course what I wanted to really involve
you okay so you have the thickness of
the slice right and what's the thickness
in this context it's it's Delta Y is it
okay so there you go there's a shape and
from this we evaluate the limits we go
to zero and then you say okay now I know
what this is called this is an integral
and you get this familiar result that
we've seen before
okay well just pies there yep that's
good a squared minus a squared okay so
we've seen this before
good now what happens when you get one
of these guys out or should I say when
you get one of these guys out okay so
Harry is right so this is I've tried to
do the innermost one okay obviously as I
would go further out I would just have
bigger shells wouldn't I
okay in this case they'd all be the same
height but I guess they're on their
radius would change from there maybe a
bigger diameter okay
no before we held this thing up and I
said what's the how do I work at the
volume you told me area and then we
multiplied by that if intestinal a small
thickness okay well hmm
the advantage of having on this thing
out is that you see the thickness is
going to be the same it's gonna be some
Delta something okay but it'll be
different shells okay
this volume right it's not about it's
not about a vertical thickness right
that's that's what these are these are
all stacked up on each other vertically
okay these are not stacked up on each
other vertically right in fact what's
going on it has changes in X right it's
a Delta X which is the small thickness
okay so instead of this start I'm gonna
have this the limit is going to be Delta
X approaching 0 okay now what am i
adding up again you select your
boundaries but they're going to be X
boundaries because my little areas that
I'm forming my volume down off
you're all going to be lined up along
the x-axis right so you got it from one
boundary oops keep the next one okay now
pause this part here has to do with the
annulus right and and all these pieces
are from the shape of a mass and how you
work out the area of an annulus when you
work out the area of this thing well so
you want to talk about this right is
that um if you think about the right way
it's a trivially simple area right
because if all I do is this it's a
rectangle right I can do rectangles all
I need to know is how high this thing is
right at any given point and don't
forget it can change just like these
guys here and then I just need to know
how far across it is it's a rectangle
right so what I want is I want to know
when I when I unfold this out like this
I want to know this height okay and then
we'll know this distance there hold on a
second what is this distance if you
remember where did I get it from and the
answer is I got it from what happens how
do you know cuz I'm so easily amused how
do I turn this into how do I do it
I cut it right
where does it come from it looks to me
like that's up that that long line
there's this guy come on you can tell me
what is what is it
it's the circumference across the top
right let's go conferences around okay
you get it right so the circumference of
course is too high oh right if you know
what R is okay so now I can put this
together now okay instead of this
business in here just business in here
which is about big circle - little
circle this nice big circle - the little
circle here there's no circles once you
think about what the area is it's a
rectangle okay so that's why what you're
getting here is going to be two pi now
in exactly the same way this big radius
in this loon radius actually functions
and they change that's why we use the
integration for this okay now there you
go there is the rectangle the rectangle
here it is okay question a rectangle has
no volume but I'm adding up volumes what
do I need what's my missing piece to
make this into a warm you it's on its
thickness isn't it its thickness which
in this case is Delta X okay there you
go
okay so just like before I can do this
thing which is this is the adding up the
slices this is adding up the shells and
I can turn this into the integral which
you're more familiar with okay this time
you get a whole two pie at the front
here soup I integrate from A to B oh yes
in this case right obviously if I was
not rotating on this axis everything
would be swamped right everything would
be swapped these would all be exes in
here then these would all be wise but
you get the idea this is just one
example okay the important thing is you
get what's going on from here to here
and here to here but I've seen people
get confused from this they're like ah
there are circles and then they go to
shells and then they try and put circles
into there there are no circles right
when you unfill Michelle you just get a
rectangle simple okay